timing joue et on peut jouer avec linda
page avec le sampler déjà commencé à
jouer avec le sampler la fête avec elle
voilà quelle façon comme vous voulez
c'est lui qui décide c'est le patron
lundi soir j'ai demandé d'enlever ton
petit pull oui c'est bien si je pouvais
enfin là il ya un petit blanc là bas on
va te dire quelque chose et on me dit
peut-être vous pourriez quitter le
plateau parce que ça a bien marché la
semaine dernière quand bedos est partie
des missions de gîtes non non je crois
que ça fait de l'audience
non non non déjà là et d'une je
t'emmerde terry avec tout le respect que
je te dois je préfère rester là je suis
très bien ici je reste eu envie de
rester
d'accord je vais rester ici je suis très
bien je vais [ __ ] la merde je vais je
lui posais des questions à la con te
voir qui va se barrer bon et ça les
questions à la con bon il y donc elie
semoun au palais des glaces c'est la
promo qui commence là attention alors
les textes sont d'elie semoun celle de
franck dubosc et muriel rome ça je me
dis à chaque fois que vous reçoit dans
une émission que ça me fait rire vous
étiez je dis à chaque fois avec muriel
robin dans la troupe des baladins de la
jeunesse qui étaient justes seront
traitées la troupe de roger
non mais j'ai une très bien avec muriel
robin dans les baladins de la jeunesse
sous la direction de roger louret qui
fait les années tubes et je tiens à
féliciter d'ailleurs je devais être
quelque chose d'extraordinaire c'est à
dire que moi j'étais habillé en petit
bouffon a laissé la jeune première
s'appelle et folie amoureuse on en
parlait dans une langue qu'ils ne se
parlent plus qu'ils s'appellent le
français
c'est une pièce classique l'annoncé
était assez surréaliste où est
maintenant avec avec le recul si non non
ça va ces deux noms je tenais à préciser
pour observer sur le service public
quand même que cette pièce et de regnard
son régne à rémy hanf aussi être
intéresser les gens ben tu peux culturel
en même temps que culturel en soit on
attend alors dans cette cassette qu'on
voit à l'écran pendant qu'on en parle 1
il ya douze sketches
alors on verra tout à l'heure celui
qu'on a choisi nous qui s'appelle griffi
en phase iib sont tous
ils sont tous assez insensé il y à 12
personnages et alors on s'est mis
vendredi dernier avec ma femme au lit on
a regardé la cassette parce qu'on savait
que vous êtes à femmes dans un lit avec
la télé peut y aller au bout du lit et
on a mis la cassette elie semoun et on a
hurlé mais de rire illégal oui c'est
aussi bien oui c'est aussi bien mais là
comment on avait envie de se remettra en
jeu le remettre en tête mais je pose une
question et dit quand on vous voit à la
télé comme ça on vous mettra un peu sous
un chapeau comme on dit chez moi si vous
êtes un peu cool calme pas très et dès
que vous entrez sur une scène vous êtes
complètement déjanté gravers que je suis
ne suis pas perpétuellement
représentation soit ça que je veux dire
non c'est pas ça bien entendu mais la
différence entre autres du genre je suis
oui je suis fou dans la vie je suis
normale sur scène je suis pas normal
avec clermont bayonne annonce que c'est
trop long alors vous avez déclaré elie
semoun cote il ya certaines phrases qui
provoquent des hurlements chez moi c'est
moi vous avez déclaré elie semoun
l'humour pour moi quand j'étais désolé
je suis désolé l'humour pour moi quand
j'étais petit c'était je vous étiez un
peu de shit naître quoi peut être pas
très bien gaulée
et vous avez déclaré donc l'humour pour
moi c'était comme des grands excuse moi
je suis désolé je vais les cales et la
rigolade pour moi c'est comme des gants
de boxe
ouais c'est à peu près ça c'est pas
qu'on vous appelez plus j'étais petit
quand j'étais petit donc donc on avait
associé à une petite fille qui
s'appelait pupuce aussi et quand j'étais
en colonie de vacances mais mes copains
élèves m'avait forcé à l'embrasser sur
la bouche
et alors et c'est l'humiliation de ma
vie quoi vous avez embrassé jusque là
que dès que les garçons quoi voilà c'est
ça c'était la dixième j'étais homosexuel
et puis n'avoue jamais je vais pouvoir
maintenant des photos de vous justement
à cette époque
s'ils voulaient bien prendre votre petit
viseur les regarder vous anime les
coudes vous avez aimé les commentaires
j'ai ce qu'on peut passer en noir et
blanc est ce qu'on va passer et vie
semoun en noir et blanc
ce sera un raccord avec l'époque fut la
peur de passer
j'étais min alors ça c'est qu'à l'époque
c'est qu'à l'époque ça ça c'était il ya
six mois la regarder ton émission et sam
abal ans j'étais petit je sais pas quel
âge avait mais c'était à l'époque où je
faisais quelqu'un dans ma culotte
voilà est ce qu'on peut voir la photo
suivante s'il vous plaît vous êtes bien
voilà c'est bien ça c'était à quel
endroit là c'est quand j'ai fait la
couverture de playboy
c'était je sais pas c'était probablement
en vacances et
je ne sais pas franchement je sais pas
on va voir la troisième photo parce
qu'avant là vous êtes vraiment comme
aujourd'hui voilà tu sais faire
c'était à l'ironie comme ça un petit
bijou villa et je dis ah ouais
très joli il a rejoint il ya l'équipe
était bien et alors après vous avez bon
vous avez vous après cette époque là
n'en apprécie pas que j'ai passé un truc
grave votre mère a disparu donc énoncé
oui est ce que c'est en rencontrant
dieudonné que vous allez retrouver l'âme
soeur non non il m'a pas servi d'âmes
soeurs non non mais c'est simplement que
moi j'aime les paradoxes dans la vie et
je me suis dit un petit juif un gros
noir c'est rigolo quoi je pense que
c'est un discours qu'on va passer au
magnéto serge munté calmement on va on
va passer au magnéto